b b b we're just going to jump right in
with Miss Pat
question um are nose bleeds a part of
being pregnant can you explain my nose
bleeds no what you have no bleed why is
my nose I don't think I've ever had a
nose bleed in my life oh wow you you
were saying your lips are very chap so
it just couldn't really be you dry it
just could be like I had cuz I'm hot all
night I'm like and I turn the AC on it
could just be that yeah you probably
just dry is this normal pad my nose is
I've never had a nose bleed in my life
am I when did I become that dork well I
had a nose bed because I got punched in
it so it wasn't doing
pregnancy when did you get punched I
plenty of time brothers friends somebody
slapped me quite a few times coming up I
mean I can't think of a braver person
than someone that would and believe I
believe you I punched the fuck back okay
go Miss Pat is here so um you have a new
show uh Miss Pat settles it my Pat will
you say what you said when you saw this
poster I said that looks like the
perfect television show I can't think of
a show that I want to watch more just
based on the poster so this is like you
uh like settling court cases y real
cases real families real situations uh
for bet if and you know what I I came
out with this ideal and I took it
started talking to the network about it
and I didn't want myself in it I wanted
to somebody else he's like why you why
don't you do it and I'm like I'm a
convicted felon I don't think I could be
a judge and they was like it's TV you
can be Jesus so I was like okay I give
it a try and you know at the time we
shooting everybody's on strike you you
can only do non strip it and everything
just came up came out I mean I can't
they you're the only person whose
opinion I respect at this point like I
truly like I cannot wait what was like
were there any that like stand out was
being particularly uh it was quite a few
of them that stood out one was this guy
suing his best friend uh for a dog he
was gay so he would go off on the
weekend and get with his Boo and just
abandon his dog so his friend changed
her name to
myangelo and the guy brought her in and
wanted the damn wanted the dog back
that's what he said so I gave him the
dog back he really didn't want the dog
he wanted the money so he was so shocked
when he
won so I'm like uh but you suit her for
the dog he's like uh I really want the
dog but people are so wild so I don't
know if you've had this like since
you've gotten like really famous on
television have you had people come out
of the woodwork and like you know try to
Sue or like neighbors try to pull weird
stuff on you like for examp like when I
first started getting Billboards for a
television show this must have been 13
years ago all of a sudden I my
accountant calls me because I had an
accountant that just did my taxes and
said you're being sued in small claims
court and I'm like what like what could
I get sued for and he's like don't worry
this is just a rack that people do when
they see you on a billboard they'll say
something like this guy who was a cab
driver who said she hit my
cab they Bank on the fact that it's
small claims and if you don't show up
because they assume you're just too busy
because you're on a TV show you're
working you probably have the money it's
$6,000 and if you don't show up usually
just goes to the other person so it's
like a it's a good racket like I wish I
had known about it like when I was broke
like I would have been like oh that's
really smart just sue a person that you
think is like famous and busy in small
claim
they won't hear about it they won't get
the summons they won't show up cuz
they're busy and he scheduled it on
Christmas Eve on um the 24th when
normally people are out of town but what
this motherfucker didn't know is that I
don't have a family I don't have plans
on Christmas Eve I'm at The Comedy Store
normally I'm like $6,000 is a lot of
money I'm going I'm going to show up he
sues me for hitting his cab I go I get
there he's like with his friends hanging
out kind of laughing I think this is
something that they just did I sat
through a full day of small claims it
was so fascinating the case before mine
was a guy who was suing another man for
stealing his bull
Sean like he had a prize Bull and and he
was accusing the other guy of coming
jerking off his bull taking the seamen
to go breed it I was like I I'm I just
want to be in court all day watching
crazy people so what happened with your
case my case I ended up winning because
he just thought I wasn't going to show
up and I was able to prove this is where
I was the day that he accused me there's
no way could have hit his cab here but
if I hadn't showed up because I was some
Hollywood asshole who just like didn't
care or was too busy or you know it's
it's weird that you said that because I
just had somebody sue me in for small
claim courts and say they fell on my
property and they never worked for me so
and it's in some I called and I was like
I don't know these people so I'm like I
don't know what you're talking about so
now I'm going to go home and diing and I
think the court date is at the end of
November that's probably what they're
doing so end of November Thanksgiving
they know you have a family and they
know you're going to be hanging out with
your family but can't you count to sue
if you don't show up cuz you don't know
anything about their case yeah but then
you're also I think a lot of these
people Bank on the fact that suing
someone's a hassle it's going to cost
you money to sue them back you're busy
you're making money you're on a hit show
you're touring they might look at your
tour dates and go oh she's in
Tallahassee this day so I'm going to go
to take her to court that day if she
doesn't show up the the judge is going
to go oh well this Hollywood asshole
Miss Pat's too busy to show up for the
court case it's probably she's probably
guilty or whatever you know like and
it'll just default to that person it's
small claims it's like5 $6,000 you walk
away with five grand where they going to
get it from that's a good point I guess
you'd have to pay it mean dud I just go
in your account no I guess they would
just send you s and then it would go to
I guess collections or something if you
didn't pay it you know or maybe if you
work for the oh they could also take it
out of your paycheck if you work for the
state maybe but I don't know he my bus
my uh accountant at the time said just
pay this just like give them the $6,000
like it's not and I was like no dude
that's a lot of money to me right now
you know know like I was making money
but I still had a whole family support
and I couldn't deal with the I was like
I'm not going to set a press in it that
people can just take advantage like this
this is you know but yeah that's a big
thing I mean people like I fell on your
property I was never on your property
you can I don't even know these people
yeah you can prove so you know you could
also have someone go in your PL like I
think you can kind of send a lawyer to
go for you I wanted to go I was like I
wanted to look I'm going to go too I
wanted to look at this guy in the eye
and just be like you like picked the
wrong bitch on the wrong day like I'm
sorry that you're your circumstances
that this is what you have to do for
money or whatever but I showed up he had
like a fancy belt buckle he didn't even
recognize you when as soon as I came in
he knew it was me because I introduced
myself I was like hi I'm the person that
didn't hit your cab what's up and he had
his friends there I think they like make
a day of it like they just you sue
people and just like celebrities and
like assume they're not going to show up
and then when you're in court you're
going like oh I sued Miss Pat I slipped
and fell on her property she didn't even
have the decency to show or respect to
show up this is the kind of person she
is you know if she showed up like you
know I would love to hear the evidence
that I'm wrong but she's not here here's
the proof here are the photos today you
can Photoshop anything you can fake any
kind of email any kind of claim I went
to the doctor here's my you know
doctor's note here's the you know
oxycoton I took here's my x-ray like
whatever and then we'll probably make a
convincing argument and you know judges
are like just want to move through their
day so they're like all right what's six
grand to Miss Pat nothing six grand is a
lot to Miss Pat cuz I would take all my
money out of my account and put it in my
titty you would not get anything from me
you would not cuz I don't even fucking
know you that's wild hired a law you got
like a like a a lawyer and everything
they got no I just I just called and I
said I don't know what these people
talking about I've never done this I
don't no what are you talking about uhuh
no because they would have yeah I had to
get the employee Insurance in case
someone did fall on my property or
something I already have that but that
person never worked for me that's insane
so I think they just drove by and say
I'm going say I'm fell over here what
bitch I'm the contractor so where did
you fall at nowhere oh tried to say it
was one of the workers oh wow no it was
not no well also if you're a worker and
you were doing work on it if it was I'm
at my house every day if it was wet you
would have gotten it wet yes I mean but
I was always at my house so nobody ever
fell at my property literally if I'm not
home my husband is there I'm the general
contractor for my house yes and they
should have said something to you if
they did nobody ever fa I'm there eating
lunch watching them for once I don't
want them to steal my wood for two I
don't want them to steal anything for
three I just want to make sure the shit
is done right so I st my property at all
times if you get work done on your house
you got to like a hawk you got to just
be there yeah cuz contractors a piss on
your flow they'll do anything so I'm
always at my property yeah yeah and it's
also it's like you know it's like we're
all human like I get you know it's like
desperate it's a desperate time right
now you know what I mean and people are
doing Ain no desperate time there some
lazy fuckers out here a no damn
desperate time if how is it desperate
times when you can sell pussy on the
internet I
mean when I was selling pussy it was on
VCR tapes you had to mail them you had
to wait seven days to get your payment I
mean you had to edit them it's no work
to this shit now it's not desperate time
the rewind yes it's so many ways to make
money now by sitting at home at doing
absolutely nothing no it's not desperate
time it's lazy ass people it's so true
and it's also It's Tricky it's like the
easier things get the lazier people get
I feel like things have never been
easier and all people do is complain
about how hard it is exactly lazy
fuckers yeah but I'm going to go dig out
that court day soon as we finish this
shit yeah like I don't I was like I will
make time I showed up on Christmas Eve
I'm I'm I know it's this month I was
just talking to my husband I said I'm
going to drive down to this shitty ass
court day and see who is this swiming
cuz I don't know this person good and
then you're going to show up and they're
going to get all spooked and then
they're not going to have a case and
you're going to go in and just like make
it clear like if you just go in with a
list of the workers that on your
property or whatever that's it and then
they dismiss it okay and then it goes on
that person's record that they had some
frivolous lawsuit cuz that was the other
thing I was like I don't want this
person going to do this to other people
too you know what I mean because like a
lot of people think that just because
you're on TV you're rich no I'm not yeah
look at me I'm not looking right down
I'm not rich I wish I was rich and I'm
not on a major Network so you know I'm
not fucking
Rich BS I'm okay even if I was on one
I'm still just okay so I am having a kid
pivoting hard here you're the only
person whose parenting advice I
want am I allowed this is a big and
you're now a judge on a big TV show am I
allowed to pinch my child pinch okay so
then spank slap
whip Miley Miley Shake tap the hand when
I when I was growing up if you made a
fit if you made like a fuss and through
a fit in a grocery store there would
just be a pinch on the back of your neck
and you would be escorted out of the
grocery store I didn't I don't feel
abused by that it worked perfectly like
just a little and I see my friends with
their kids and I'm like I know how to
solve this it's just a little pinch it
just stuns them yes I I I please pinch
your child cuz that's nothing like a
badass kid in a public places that's
running over their parents and they're
looking at them like can you please like
we're in public I'm like why are you
trying to reason with a child that has
no concept black mother say I will slap
the fucking black off of you you know
how many times we heard that make me
make you
vigaro is that what it's called Vigo
vialago
was that a country I just
say I thought it was like I used to have
a skin infection when I was a kid called
impo imp had like vgo mortson cuz he was
really palea make me slap you Michael
Yes beat the shit out of you don't
fucking play with me but don't you feel
like people now they want to be friends
with their kids like you're not you're
not your kids friend I'm not I'm never I
had a baby at 14 everybody know that so
I'm never your fucking kid my kids are
36 37 and I tell them don't fucking cuss
in front of me I'll whoop you in your
kiss ass so it's all about respect
you're not going to show out on me
you're not you're not going to act a
fool because you got me fucked up uhhuh
I'm just I'm sorry I'm not going to sit
here and say we're in public I'm say I'm
going to beat your fucking ass if you
don't get up off that floor and I don't
give a fuck about going to jail cuz I've
been get the fuck up out that floor
that's all I can say I'm not g to say
and reason with you I'm no DN mom the
next thing you know you gonna be bossing
me around I said I wanted Chick-fil-A
today bitch it's Sunday
I I can't get you no fucking Chick-fil-A
on no Sunday so I'm going to stop it now
it's also like what how much like what
are we doing did you go full Santa Claus
full Easter Bunny the whole
thing well wait when I had a kid in the
seventh grade i i i Ain I ain't get no
damn Crim me and the keys both was
looking for Christmas doll you still
believed in Santa Claus at the time no I
you
know cuz I do I remember as a kid
knowing it was a lie and being like why
are you guys lying to me like well in
the hood they tell you ain't no white
man brought you shit but a
warrant I know I'm G to give birth on
this black black people tell you a no
goddamn white man came out by here with
shit free I bought that shit it was on
left at
Walmart that's what black parents say
hopefully that white shit so they black
family killed white Santa Claus long
time ago for us oh what the fuck you a
ask that that nigga for
nothing so no the kids
a ain't nobody fucking with no white s
and then we put him in a black costume I
don't know that nigga I just want you to
get a picture with him he bought me shit
so black mothers kill black parents is
killed the shit
for my mom said I don't got no 7 CL you
know I got my appointment to go down
there pick up them free toys for you
niggas and
I and I ain't rapping that shit either
I'mma throw it behind my mama never rap
that shit she
so back in the day we were
literally you going to be okay I leave
her I think I'm going deliver we would
have appointment to go pick up the toys
for the PO kids which was us and each po
kids got two items and Mom it was five
of us my mom say look here niggas y'all
pick this shit cuz I got to get back
home while Young and Restless
so we would go down the line and pick
two of the shittiest items that you
could ever see and she would say don't
you niggas make pick nothing with noise
I don't want to hear that
shit so we want L you know them little
popcorn things oh we got one of them one
she beat the dog shit out of us with
it she don't you get a motherfucking
thing and make noise cuz you know I wake
up with a hangover so we will walk down
the aisle we will pick two toys and then
she would be at the end of the table and
you put in this black plastic bag and
she was tied up and on Christmas she'll
throw the floor y'all get the shit the
people G y'all
already we never had a Christmas tree
it's so I'm a big Christmas person but I
don't tell a white COV
lie CU I'm black as fuck but I I like
two things I love Disney and I love
Christmas it just bring that it it makes
me feel warm on the inside of a
childhood that I never had so Christmas
time I I probably have up eight
Christmas trees it's my favorite fucking
holiday so I I love Christmas but I
don't tell my kids no white man came out
here and gave us shit now come on now
this is
this is 2024 oh it's
[Laughter]
2023 all right y'all so you know that
I've been on tour you know that I travel
a lot and I'm telling you these ratchet
ass toothbrushes that that I've been
getting at the airport or that I've been
getting like the ones that just like
delicately caress your teeth but they're
not actually cleaning them the point is
I now only use quip toothbrushes this is
the electric toothbrush which is timed
with Sonic vibrations with 30second
pulses to guide a dentist recommended T
minute clean so you're not going to just
be like zoning out missing your window
this just tells you when to move it's
lightweight it has Sleek design for
adults and for kids it's got no wires or
bulky Chargers to weigh you down or trip
you and send you to your to your death
okay a multi-use travel cover that
doubles as a mirror mount for less
clutter reusable Handles in a range of
sleek metal Hues as well as bright
plastic colors sure to pop on your
bathroom counter skip the batteries snap
into new healthy habits with a new
rechargeable electric toothbrush all the
features of the original quip but this
one has magnetic charge Powers up for up
to 3 months of brushing that's crazy
this is the water flosser hits all the
right spots with gentle deep clean
pressure at the touch of a button extra
wide lid that fits right under the
faucet and fills up in seconds the
cordless rechargeable battery lasts up
to 8 weeks with daily use no bulky
charging dock or Tangled cords or God
that stuff drives me nuts you've got
like a rat king of cord nightmares this
blasts away up to
99.9% of plaque and popcorn by the way
from treated areas with Precision thanks
to the
360° rotating magnetic floss tip that
snaps into place easy to control water
flow that leaves you feeling squeaky
clean look at this it's sleek and slim
enough to keep your countertops as clean
as your teeth $7 replacement floss tips
are shipped to you every 3 months to
keep things flowing smoothly and prevent
mineral deposits from building up got to
love that and look at this you guys quip
makes gum now mint and gum look at this
every time you pop our new mints you are
going to be caring for your mouth inside
and out don't be that freak with hosis
Justin you know who I'm talking to bold
mint flavor keeps your breath
confidently fresh and you will get a
boost of vitamin D gum which prevents
cavities and then freshens breath when
chewed for 20 minutes after eating it's
sugarfree it has tooth friendly Xylitol
with zero calories long- lasting mint
flavor crunchy TR layer design look at
this slim travel ready dispenser
available in five colors metal or
plastic packs protects up to 10 pieces
of gum or minc at a time fits in any
purse any pocket any cavity that you've
got the quip electric toothbrush is
loved by over 9 million Ms track and
improve your brushing with the free quip
app earn amazing rewards like free
refills products Target gift cards and
More in addition to the brush heads quip
also delivers fresh floss toothpaste
mouthwash and gum refills every 3 months
for $7 with stylish and Affordable
Electric brushes starting at just $25
will not be paying through the teeth go
to getquip.com Whitney right now you're
going to get 20% off any electric
toothbrush mint and gum dispenser or
water flosser that's your 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com Whitney spelled get g t quip
qip
p.com Whitney quip the good habits
company I'm just trying to figure out
like the the the lengths of lying to
your kid that's okay I hate parents just
just be honest just tell them the truth
like they're because they're they're
smarter than we think I see people I
know it's like INF fantz a child they
are whatever children but at the same
time it's like I've just in big I've
always treated kids just like adults you
know what I mean and then I feel like
you know what I hate the most about
parents when they kids when they put
their kid in a sport and won't tell them
that they suck and they continue to pay
for them that's our biggest problem in
America uh so you know and everybody on
the team got to get a reward no your
baby suck okay he just out here because
you trying to get the motherfucker to
get some fresh air so tell the truth
like my son played basketball my oldest
son like he played basketball he was so
fucking horrible I said come here nigga
you wased my $130 we quit not you we
quit he was like a a unhinged Dennis
robing out there his shoes was s on his
feed he didn't know what to do he
sliding I said what the fuck are you
doing this is basketball why is you on
your stomach slide down to the other
side of the go he was so fucking
horrible and I just put him in the car
look look n you fucking suck okay and
you wasted my money we GNA stick with
football cuz for some reason you like
niggas hitting you upside your head and
you perform better and he never play
basketball
again I mean people just should be
honest I mean unless you're a child even
even if your child is is I I don't want
to get in trouble for saying this but my
my has an autistic son that I be there
you be talking to him like he just
regular shut your ass down that's what
you can't be talking the autistic
son I'm not that fucking rude he like so
he always buy his autistic son Jord and
he fuck up the Jo nigga you fucked up
the joint he's autistic he don't give a
fuck about no regular kid hey my kids
don't give a fuck about no Jordan and
I'm like stop buying him them fucking
shoes he don't care
it's got to be he finally
stopped buying buying nice shoes for an
autistic son well he stoop by cuz he's a
Jordan freak so he realized his son
don't care about him like he do so I say
just stop leave him the fuck alone yeah
I do feel like I don't want he smart as
fuck so them tennis shoes is not fucking
interesting all paint brush yes he's
smart as fuck he be telling you shit
like I really don't need to know how you
know how to son go around the earth I I
really don't want to
know but his son is so smart that I told
him one time I said my son was so dumb I
wish he had ontis my son is so fucking
dumb they they diagnos him with
shortterm memory loss they he forgot he
was playing basketball halfway through
the game no I tried to get a social
security check for him so and I thought
something wrong they said no he store
everything his short-term memory so they
said I thought he was autistic they said
nothing is wrong with him he lazy he got
diagnosed with being lazy as fuck they
told me he put everything in short-term
memory except his video game ah and he's
still playing rent to this day he's in
his 30s yeah the video games are a
tricky one because I do feel like it's
like it does make your brain it does
challenge your brain it is kind of
exercise for your brain but I guess it
depends on like which game it is which
game is he playing I have no clue now
Mario one depends on which one which one
we got I I don't I think he play
football I I don't fucking know cuz he's
you know he's married he got kids and
shit so I don't know what do you feel
like is the biggest mistake parents make
with their kids besides giving them too
much accolades when they're not good at
something I mean just being honest with
them yep just being honest you know we
we you know like I was just telling some
I said the biggest lie we tell to kids
the birds and the beads you know when
they want to talk about sex can't no
bird fuck no
bee so who the fuck came up with this
dumb ass
analogy so I know so I told my kids I
said look I'm not going to knock you
also birds lay eggs but a beer fly up
his
ass like NE neither of them have sex
anywhere close to ours yeah bees got to
have the smallest dicks in the world cuz
they only so
big I mean it might be a big dick in the
bee Community
but I mean I like that they worship a
queen like that's going in a positive
direction but but she fucks everybody
she's the only fan that's the if you're
telling kids to have sex the way bees
have sex you're saying like 50 dudes
should gang bang one Queen yes and then
eat each other's puke that's what honey
is right I I guess but I mean just be
honest with him I told my kids I said
I'm not going to tell you not to get no
dick cuz dick is delicious when it's the
right dick what I'm going to tell you is
to protect yourself cuz CU you can get
some shit out here that'll put fucking
mows on your vagina that look like
raisins that's right you know so just
protect yourself I'm I mean when you
feel like you want some dick go get it
but and I told my oldest daughter who
you I must have turned off cuz she gay
as fuck so she she went totally opposite
I didn't have a gay conversation with
her cuz I didn't know what to say go eat
pussy cuz I don't eat pussy so I was
technically trying to tell her suck a
dick it's okay but she took opposite
advice well if you told her if she's
like the dick she was get rais on her
pussy I probably would never want to be
around the dick again either I'm just
like I'm gay it turns out I'd rather
just lick a giant raisin well damn
that's what that's where I went wrong
at so I mean I'm just all and my kids
tell me I I sometime I wonder do I hurt
their feelings now because I'm so blunt
yeah but I tell if you don't the World's
Gonna well yeah and I tell them all the
time I said I'm just preparing you how
the world is going to treat you but I
love you so I'm doing it so you can be
strong and you can understand I mean I'm
just not I'm never gonna beat around the
bush I'm 51 when it when I fart in
public I don't give a fuck you know I'm
at that point you know one point you
would hold your gas nigga I gotta fart
move and it really don't stink cuz my
ass is big so yeah it got time to dilute
before it get all the way to the end of
my ass so you really don't smell you
just hear loud at what the fuck
but it's a power move yeah I'm Flex I'm
at the point where I I I'm just being
honest do you see the way that your kids
are with their kids and does it only one
of my kids have kids no my son
no no you know I try to tell my son but
you know the new age kids are so
different and I'm old school yeah I have
a 9-year-old grandbaby that has a cell
phone that I keep telling her I said do
y'all realize what you giving her you
might gave her a fucking gun I said you
know she like she got in trouble for she
you bitch ass ho ass bitch and I was
like what so I'm like take the fucking
phone yeah the only I think the thing
that phones are good for if you're going
to give them at that age is to give them
something you can punish them with
because they're so addicted to it you
can actually well I have I have cussed
my niece kids and they don't have phone
and I have two ninth grade I said let me
tell you something you had to do like we
did if you get kidnapped scream
motherfucker cuz I mean if you die
meanwhile he got you it ain't like I can
get to you that's everyone's what
everybody says they're like no we have
it so we know where they are it's like
but they also that's the same device
where other people can find out where
they are and where they can get
catfished by some weirdo who can text
and they don't give a fuck about us so
when you give them a phone you say well
I'm going to turn on your location guess
what they turn their location off
because they don't want you in their
fucking business y so you're not get no
phone you get a phone where you can pay
for your own phone that's it exactly
that's the rule yeah so my I have a kid
at the house Who Stole My Money like
$1,600 and um um I didn't even realize
he stole he stole it from my husband the
teacher call oh my god he has such a
large amount of money and I said well he
do working she said no not like this so
my grandbaby takes a picture of the
money him out there planing like he from
the hood and put it on fucking Instagram
I don't even know it till somebody else
child tells
me oh I wanted to beat her ass so I tell
him I said take this fucking phone I
said cuz what's going to happen when
somebody trick her like they her friend
and she get in a call with them and you
don't ever see them again that's right M
uh uh I said she don't need a fucking
phone she's not she don't pay no bills
she don't even know how to wash your ass
good enough so why does she have a phone
yeah unless you're doing business unless
you're rolling calls there what is there
to do I I still like if I had a cell
phone when I was 13 so many people would
be
dead what I would I mean I would go to
pay I would cause trouble from payones
you know what I mean wanted yeah and
that took 30 minutes you'd have to get
the quarter you'd put it in well well I
had a pager I got I did a lot of damage
with a pager even which was just like it
would just text the phone number and you
would just call it back I'm like I can't
even imagine the dumb the number of dumb
things that didn't happen just because
it took too long to make the phone call
or I didn't have a quarter probably
saved my life a thousand times you know
the idea that you could just press so
you didn't you didn't know anything
about dialing zero and say my call
dropped and they put you through to the
phone number shit
fuck
no stupid so back in the day when you
didn't have that quarter to make that
phone call you were M Zer on the phone
say I was just on the phone call my
phone dropped they was like oh let me
connect you shit no for free nobody ever
paid the fucking phone boo I mean I see
people I was with someone the other day
whose daughter who was 11 was calling
her mom by her first name oh hell to the
motherfucker no no no like no no you she
was like Erica Erica and I was like why
are you resp I can't understand how you
could respond to this and be okay with
this I would be like you live outside
now no I was like what is like my kids
will talk and they they'll be like yes
and I excuse you yes ma'am no you would
never call me Patricia I don't even like
Patricia it's old as fuck you're never
going to call me Pat and if you and if
somebody ask you what's my name you must
say My mama name is Patricia uhhuh you
better never say Patricia but also I if
I didn't say yes sir yes ma'am I got
slapped upside the head is what we
called it and I still say yes sir and
yes ma'am today living in I think this
is just a fucking stupid California
thing I say yes sir yes ma'am people
like oh sir like I'm like they get
offended by Sir and ma' nobody wants to
get old
anymore that's the fucking problem I
respect you don't yes maam me you can't
yes I'm going be honest with you you
cannot yes maam white women they don't
fucking like it handle it you they
cannot fucking now black women is a form
of respect yes ma'am I'm not that old
bitch it's respect you so used to not
being talked to right I can't even
respect you yes ma'am oh my God I'm only
35 well bitch you're white you look a
little older but I'm trying to respect
you you let your white daughter call you
by your first name but I can't call you
ma'am what does that say about you you
know ain't nobody calling me but that's
that's just that's cultural difference
because I mean I would it used to be
cultural different these black bitches
these days the same way probably a lot
of them but you not you're not going to
I'm 51 don't try me M I tell him don't
try me try Jesus he got more patient he
give more he give he loves you way more
than I do he came in die for you I
wouldn't die for any of you
motherfuckers so I've been sleeping on
the blissy pillowcase and let me just
tell you look at me I look amazing okay
I did not know that a pillowcase could
feel so good and make such a big
difference in my life no one told me
this they told me take sleeping pills do
this hang upside down BL no one told me
about this I mean do you do you ever
struggle to find the cool side of the
pillow like you have to flip the pillow
all the time to try to get gets all hot
and swampy not with Blissey Blissey silk
pillowcases are temperature regulating
and have naturally insulating properties
so that if you sweat and overheat when
you sleep Blissey handles it okay
Blissey fixes all that drama on top of
that it also is so good for your hair it
reduces frizz Tangles and prevents hair
breakage it keeps the moisture in your
hair and keeps your skin care prods and
natural moisture in your skin because
the silk does not absorb the moisture
off your face okay it's not going to be
leeching the youth from your face you
can say goodbye to wrinkles adios dry
flaky and red skin in the morning and
wake up with healthier hair it's time to
upgrade your sleep with blissey's
award-winning 100% Mulberry silk
pillowcases the holidays are they truly
are right around the corner it's
horrifying and if you're looking for the
best gift you can give look no further
than a blissy silk pillowcase silk is
honestly it is the most luxurious gift
you can give your friends and family I
this is the silk blissy eye cover like
the Sleep eye cover I do not go anywhere
without it it's truly my favorite thing
it's on my forehead right now look how
soft this is look at this look at this I
can't sleep without it these are the
perfect gifts for any occasion plus it
comes in gift ready packaging they're
sure to love H what doesn't Blissey
handle give yourself the gift of Blissey
today you'll want one for every room in
the house blissy silk pillowcases are
the best pillowcases on the market hands
down they have a ton of different prints
and colors and they make great gifts
because there's an option for literally
anyone men love them too don't believe
they love silk silky silk you know where
they have over 1.5 million raving fans
and you could be next try now risk-free
for 60 nights and get an additional 30%
off that's Blissey blis SS y.com Whitney
to get an additional 30% off give
yourself the gift of a good night's
sleep with
Blissey I remember like my parents
weren't around a lot like I I didn't
have a lot of discipline and it's like I
think people forget like kids want
discipline they want walls like they're
going to make a fuss but they're just
constantly testing you they're testing
you my mom wasn't really around my
parents were divorced whatever we turned
into a couple of punks like we're on the
street we're stealing money doing all
that kind of shit stealing from you know
my mom I stole money out of my mom's
purse and I can't you know she was
dating you know trying to move on dating
other men and I was like you know I was
like just I didn't understand and um I
was mad I had all this anger whatever so
she had gone on a date I took money out
of her purse when she was on a date the
next day she said do you take my money
and I said I'm 11 years old I said um uh
well you're just going to make it back
anyway because you're just a fucking
hooker and she hit me so hard open hand
across the face she should have she
should have hit you with black Jesus in
man keep going hit me I I I remember it
I cuz I remember it because the first
thought I had was thank God she finally
did it like she finally stood up to me
you know like she like that's love like
it was the first time I felt love from
her I wasn't mad at her I was like
grateful I remember she hit me I was
like falling it was like between a bed
and a wall and I remember falling and
going like I have a mom like I have
someone who can protect I have someone
who's going to make that I don't screw
my life up basically you know like it
was a relief to me I wasn't mad at her
and that was it and like from then on
like wasn't shitty to her we had like a
pretty good
relationship and it was like she finally
just stood up to me and like cuz I mean
because the divorce and everything
everyone was like so scared to you know
I think stand up to us as like kids you
know but it's like we lived in DC if she
had have done it someone else I would
have said that to someone else got your
ass beat correct correct so I remember
just like knowing in that moment like in
my cells like she probably just saved my
life or probably just saved me from like
a really rough ER visit cuz I was going
to like be running my mouth at the wrong
place and say some shit like that like I
needed to be humbled I needed someone to
just fucking discipline me and no one
would do it what that's the different
growing up black cuz my mom used always
say bitch try me and we know not to say
a damn thing so I didn't need all those
ass whopping I got I didn't need that to
let me know I had a mama she let me know
she was a fucking mama I mean that the
kids want that they want discipline they
want to know like like if you can stand
up to me you can stand up for me you
know it's just respect you know you're
going to respect me I'm your mother and
I'm going to take care of you and you're
going to respect me and you're going to
respect anybody else that's older than
you you're going to respect your third
cousin who was born the same month that
you three hours early because I said so
and that's how it should be but kids
today you know I it's a lot of
friendship instead of just you know
people stepping out and being old school
parents oh my God it's gonna traumatize
them oh my God you shouldn't say that
well why not it made you a better person
that's right like why are we protecting
kit they're gonna hit Society is so
sensitive so when I'm 51 when I was in
school they whooped your ass the
principal whooped your ass and the you
act up take your ass down out of Mr
Patterson cuz he gonna Pat your ass with
that fucking paddle but they took all of
that out and people like oh my god when
they took Jesus out the school the world
went to shit no when they took this one
and out of school look at these kids
today who stand up and whoop on teachers
we wouldn't
the most we would have did was it that's
the most and your mama got called and
you got popped in your fucking cheek but
now they standing up and I saw a girl
hit a teacher upside the head the other
day another girl jumped on the teacher
well you seen the teacher fight where
the teacher have no underwear then she
whooped her motherfucking ass so they
just have no respect but but all of that
starts at home also so if they're not
getting displine at the house they
definitely not going to come to school
with that type of discipl but also you
think like social media like it's like
like Mike Tyson said the problem today
is that people can talk shit and they
don't get punched in the face yes like
kids are on social media they're seeing
people talk shit talk shit talk shit and
they're on these like live video games
where you can talk shit with the people
you're playing video games with and they
just think they can talk shit like that
to anybody you know so it's like this
tricky thing where it's like uh like I
don't know it's like social media it's
like like when people are like oh it
makes you you know body dysmorphic and
like we had that before social media
yeah you know what I mean like it's
that's the thing that I feel like is
really like well people do shit to be
pop
like and I'm just being honest I've
never heard the word anorexic when I was
coming up first of all we was on food
stamp if you threw up my mama food she
would beat your motherfucking ass I
don't care if it was bad you better
swallow it you better swallow it and if
you want to work it off you better take
your ass around that block and walk but
just throwing up her food St we done
waited 30 days for you would get a fuck
my mom will beat the shit out of you so
you know and and back in those days
nobody nobody really looked at you for
how you look all you had to do have a
pretty face you be a fat girl and you
was as long as you was pretty but now
you know they set these standards you
supposed to be thin you supposed to be a
certain way you know because everybody
can be a model and everybody can be on
Instagram and it give false sense of
reality then when you really meet these
motherfuckers without them a filter that
filter done shaped these bitches they
look like motherfucking Mike tyon like
they been like Mike Tyson punched them
in the face you like bitch this was not
you
we don't we don't we too scared at a as
America as women to take a picture
without a fucking filter and I'm one of
them you know you I am a little o oily
here but sometime I don't give a fuck
like I do my podcast my wig be slide I'm
not dressing up for you motherfuckers to
talk to
you I'm not doing that shit this is a
lot of makeup I got on today I had to
wash my ass if I'm at the house doing my
podcast I'm going to throw on a hat
let's get this shit done somebody say
how can you go on your podcast how can
you click me the fuck off your computer
cuzz I don't give a fuck about
you you better leave me the fuck alone
you either listen or you here to see
what I look like you see me with makeup
Google motherfucker I'm out there with
makeup with a little makeup heavy makeup
and without makeup you choose a Miss Pat
you want a motherfucking like but what
I'm not going to do is dress up for you
motherfuckers cuz I'm fat I got to lift
my stomach I got to shave my thighs F
y'all go to
hell that was like it is so true I
sometimes wish I just did like an audio
only podcast remember during the
pandemic I had like all those different
color hair and when you no one tells you
when you bleach your hair and make it
blue or purple or whatever everyone
already thinks you're a drug addict but
I didn't brush it like I didn't put the
oil on it like it just would get dry and
I just look like you know like french
fries were coming out of my head and it
was just like she's on drugs she's I'm
like I'm not going to curl my hair every
day because that's going to make the
hair drier and break even more I'm like
who am I even doing this for like I
don't even like know any but I do think
that like podcast like we signed up to
be comedians at a time where you would
Tour all year once a year maybe once
every two years you would be seen and
shoot a special you would maybe do The
Tonight Show you would do this now it's
like every week we're on camera for like
three hours and it's just like not me I
don't get made up for I don't give a
fuck there'll be days I sit that Ain got
on no bras or no panties I don't care
but I'm I'm I'm GNA do my podcast cuz I
don't do it for them I do it for me I
like talking now I do like the
interaction with my fans I just had a
big party called Miss P fan celebration
that I do once a year in Atlanta and
they come from all around the world but
they know me I call them you know I call
them my crack babies but I I don't have
time for that I've learned a long time
ago I it's about me you got to make
yourself happy that's it because I'm not
going to live for you cuz if I live for
you I'm going to die for I'm I'm going
to die so it's about me fuck everybody
else what have you learned like in like
you know your show is about to go into
another season yeah four SE fourth
season of the Miss so insane like have
there been any like learning curves as
far as like being a boss being a leader
um or is parenting it's pretty similar
to Parenting I feel well one of the
things I learned with working with a
network you know everybody don't have
your vision even though they give you
these deals they always got people
behind the scene that see something
different you know and that's one of the
biggest things I had to work work with
and work through is say hey I know funny
you know corporate I know funny I got
here because I was funny I didn't get
here because what you have in mind I got
here because of what I have in mind so
just to be able to tell you know and I
love working with bet because they black
they understand it took them a minute to
understand me but like we don't do this
for talent I like well I'm not Talent we
we we're co-workers you know and if if
this work for me it works for you so we
all in this together so just mainly to
get the network to listen to and and
support your idea to give it a try like
cuz I have a show that had never been
done we cussing in a sitcom a multicam I
mean we talking and people really love
that this is the first time a mother
like me ever had a voice on national TV
and and people like this this shit is
crazy but it's so many Mis Pats out
there and the subject that bet and vom
allow us to do is real edgy like I did
my mama boyfriend molested me um I did
my kid's father molested me how he
treated me being shot I tell it all but
it's also if something like this
happened to us why is it too edgy for TV
I reality I had to live through it yeah
so it's like this so so oh but that's
too upsetting to people yeah I had to
live through it it's sponsors Todd don't
want to hear you got fucked with a deal
dop they trying to get they trying to
get you to wash your clothes not cry we
used tide to wash the blood
off and it worked great no blood stains
in my panties Dad we need a
commercial we need a commercial T it
washed my uncle's fingerprints right off
my panties
yes it happened you guys I'm pregnant I
know I know I I froze my eggs I talked
about that a lot in my HBO special
everyone thinks I like had sex with a
Tesla or something I got pregnant
naturally I know it happened I'm going
to be a mom I am very excited to find
out the sex of my baby I'm using sneak
peek it is a super convenient at home
way to find out really early see I want
I want to know the sex of my kid I I
know people are I want to be surprised I
feel like there going to be enough
surprises on the day I give birth to
this tiny little vampire I want to
reduce the number of surprises in the
labor and delivery emergency room as I
struggle to not die in child
birth their founder Chris developed this
product because he and his wife they
wanted to stop calling the baby it which
I think is kind of funny it makes me
think of the clown and the sewer like a
little baby in
the and Chris and his wife they wanted
to connect with the baby earlier instead
of waiting for 20 weeks okay well they
have a much less shallow reason than I
do but sneak peek is the only at home
baby sex test that lets you know boy or
girl as early as 6 weeks into pregnancy
months earlier than an ultrasound
results are 99.9% accurate and
clinically proven everything you need is
packaged in this compact box this test
is trusted by over 1 million moms and
OBGYNs mail it back in the prepaid
package and get results on the same day
that your sample arrives at the sneak
peak Labs right now sneak peek is
offering my listeners up to $20 off just
go to sneak peek test.com and use my
code Whitney to save up to $20 to today
that's sneak peek
test.com sneak s n a k Peak PE K test te
s.com and save $20 today all right let's
gender this baby this is super easy
first you're going to drink 8 ounces of
water 20 minutes before to help the
blood flow right then you're going to
remove the adhesive on the snap and
stick it on and it doesn't hurt at all
that's crazy all right it's working see
guys I'm human look at that red blood
coming out so when this is done I'm
going to take the vial out I'm going to
snap the cap on top of the vial I'm
going to put it inside this little
baggie and then we put it back in the
box with the shipping label and Presto
mailo now I'm ready to send this off to
sneak peek and I'm going to get my
results on the sex of my baby the day it
hits the
laboratory give it to the
stor I remember when I wrote my first
book and uh people's like oh you got to
take that out it just so it's it's gonna
make people cry well I want people to
feel what I felt I don't water me down
and I argue you to I'm Not Gon to
fucking do it I don't need your money
I'm you not g to make me this fat bitch
that's in your head cuz I'm I mean I'm
I'm a person where I come with scars and
bruises and kicks and and roll down
heels let me show you my motherfucking
healing and that's what I like about bet
but I've argued I've had to AR
off off finale um where uh the daddy
grabs me and we get we kind of like a
fight and the some of the women in the
network really love how we created Terry
on the show as as this such supportive
husband you know he support his wife
career he takes care kids and everything
well I get an abortion and I don't tell
him well I told him it was my decision
and at 50 I could be risking my life and
they they was already etchy with the
fucking episode but he grabs me because
I got an abortion and he asked me not to
and he like oh my God he can't grab you
and I remember looking at the camera say
leave me the fuck alone I know how to
get
beat and it blew the fuck up it blew I
mean it split the audience how dare she
then women was like I understand her I
can't believe Terry put his fucking
hands on her they were so invested in
that episode because if that episode
weren't you you KNE if if you if that
episode didn't represent you you knew
people who had gone through
and that's why I wrot episode it was me
and I also knew people who had G through
that and it was just so true to reality
and people loved it and that's like what
art and television does at its best like
that's what we do at our best is we show
people even if you haven't been through
this other people have and you don't get
to just look away you know and it's
going to be funny funny funny and then
it's going to break your heart and then
you can't look away and you have to um
step into somebody else's shoes for a
second you have to feel someone else's
feelings for a second but what's
happening in Hollywood right now is
everyone's so afraid to make anyone
uncomfortable or trigger anybody or
upset anybody it's making bad television
it's making bad art it's making art that
doesn't it's supposed to change you
forever that's what it's supposed to do
yes and and I'm not going to I'm not
going to make that kind of TV no I I
don't know how to make that kind of TV
cuz it no matter what I create it's
always going to be some type of reality
in it it's got to be real it's got to be
real to the people sitting there say oh
my God that's me that's all I hear when
I go on the road mom is p say I'm you or
you my mama you my aunt oh my God you
was talking to me with this episode or
you was you know it's for the people
yeah and if if they're not interested
they're not going to watch the shit and
it's also like part of like like for me
it's like if I didn't have like the
whatever trauma that I've had and the
abuse that I've had I would just be a
crazy entitled bitch yeah but if we have
the context of what I come from you're
like oh this is so triumphant that she's
confident and has a voice and can speak
up for herself and can use laughter to
cope yeah whereas if I was just from
from like a fancy house in Connecticut I
would just be an annoying asshole nobody
would like
you and and only I would say this bitch
please where did you come from you know
it's not reality I don't want to hang
out with somebody like that who a't got
no feeling who been handed everything
don't even know it and it's nothing
wrong with I don't care how rich you are
I just want you to be aware that
everybody don't have what you have yeah
you know you can't you just can't you
know even with the little money I got
there I just can't say hey y'all we
let's go on vacation like bitch we got a
job well so do I but we don't get paid
the same and so I tell my friends hey
y'all y'all want to go to Disney Cru we
got one year to pay for this bitch we
going to make all payments at the same
time and that's what I still do to this
day cuz everybody money ain't the same
that's right and and I've not changed I
still hang out with the same people but
I know that what I make is totally
different for what my friends made my
retired girlfriends my friends with
grandkid so I don't come and say I'm
going to dig y'all ready I said nuh I
said I want y'all to experience
something but we going to put this
motherfucker on lay we going to break
the payments down and that's what we do
and that's so tricky because I've I mean
I like people think that I have like all
this I've spent most of my money on my
family and I don't regret it it was you
know both my parents had Strokes like 10
years ago without health insurance like
I I mean in America ICU if you don't
have health insurance is $60,000 a day
and I like I was just I mean I was doing
casinos to try to pay for nursing homes
and Hospital you know it's just like
both my par caretakers like you know
it's a nightmare and um and so you know
I mean the Universe I feel like if if I
had gotten to keep any of that money I
probably would have done something
stupid with it or who knows like maybe
I'd be you know died of fet all by now
or something so I was just like try to
be grateful and go God whatever but you
know you could also it's America these
are doctor bills you could have walked
away from you know I you could have got
Medicaid Medicare you can always pay
broke you mean they didn't have your
income see when that's when you you have
to call me for the reality of what's
really going on how to get away sh you
just being white and paying your fucking
bills you got to stop that
shit that's what we pay off taxes for I
am so dumb like honestly I no you just
don't you don't call your black friend
enough call me Miss Pat what would
Negroes do don't say
that I had my credit was so bad at that
point Byron Allen helped me fix my
credit I finally got to a point where I
could rent an apartment lease a car and
then these bills started hitting me and
it was just like crushing me and um yeah
I'm an idiot and I paid for it all but
I'm like now at a point I was talking to
Leslie Jones about this yesterday we
were trying to I was just like what's
like because I want to share with every
like when I I know what it's like to be
in debt it's the worst when I see a
friend who's like struggling and has
credit card debt or something like I
just want to pay it off so bad and like
I have before sometimes it works but
there's other time or and like they
truly feel better grateful doesn't
doesn't toxify the relationship but I
remember Chris Rock said to me once like
um he was like when you loan someone
money it's only a matter of time before
they start to hate
you because there have been so many
friendships where I'll just be like Oh
no I got that or like I'll cover that or
like you know your kid wants to do this
thing and you can't afford it like let
me just let me just get it for you I'll
I'll try to go like oh it'll be like an
early Christmas gift or like oh you know
what I won't get you a wedding gift I'll
just like do this and then the
relationship starts to get weird and
then now I feel like I have a power over
you that I don't want to have and like
now
you know what I mean like it's like do
you have a protocol for that yeah I do I
do jokes and my joke is uh I didn't give
you n my crack money I didn't give you
none of my uh my check foring money you
get none of my motherfucking TV
money so I do that bit every
night yeah I mean you can't save the
world like you you I have friends out
there you know and they're struggling or
whatever if I can help I can help but
but I'm not going to say oh let me get
that for you no I'm not going that's
life you know and my friends don't
expect me to do that don't I always
learn don't start nothing that you don't
want to keep up that's why I don't walk
right now TR it walk yeah just just like
exercising yeah yeah treadmill cuz then
you'd have to finish the walk no I have
to do it every fucking day so you just
don't start nothing in this world that
you don't want to keep up right now
exercising me is arguing like a
motherfucker and I need it I'm a plump
bitch right now so you know and and I
just tell I'm not loaning you money I'm
not Bank of America I I don't have it to
loan you know my husband is retired we
on a we on a fucking fixed income yeah
you know and I I got bad
habits that's my main bad habit is like
you know because yeah is is giving PE or
just trying to fix someone else's thing
and it's not and it's also like if you
fix they going to ref fuck it up you
going to fix it again that's exactly it
huh it's plastic surgery you get it
eventually your cheeks going to fall
titties you buy them eventually your
titties going to fall you going to lift
them back up or you going you buy your
friend titties and you know she couldn't
afford them fucking titties when they
fall in 20 years are you going to be
back there to pick up them titties so
don't buy the bitch the titties she
couldn't afford the titties the first
fucking place things leak sometimes yeah
they leak youo them and she going to
tell you you bought me these titties and
they fucking leak and you got to fix
them no bitch I didn't tell you to go
around bumping niggas upside their head
with the titties
you I didn't tell you I told you not to
go through the X-ray machine at the
airport what do they do yes yes so no
what's going to happen to my tits and
should I be breastfeeding because I have
fake ones I don't know I don't know my
shit is real so you got to ask a bitch
you got those bab now I can't answer
everything I I can't tell you shit about
no fake titties do they work I we'll see
I know mean when you when somebody suck
them do you feel it like half well
that's kind of good because you know
when baby uh when the baby breast feet
they clamp down they said that shit hurt
my my daughter uh clamped down on my
titties when I the only child I ever
tried to breast feet I said no bitch
this Ain for me uhuh that's the number
one advice I'm getting it's like don't
try to be a hero on breastfeed you do
not have to and you know I I don't knock
the moms who snatch they titties out and
breastfeed everywhere cuz it's some of
the most I don't even let me just say
this I don't even know how is the
motherfucking the most healthiest milk
that a child can get when when I've seen
bitches who smoke weed and breastfeed my
sister smoke crack and breastfeed so you
telling me getting that baby high every
day is more healthy than
Similac whole milk so I don't and what
is this bitch eating is she just eating
healthy if she up here eating a Snicker
bar you going to tell me her breast milk
is good no I'm not going to sit down and
I mean and more power to you if you
breastfeed cuz it's it's the right thing
to do but I'm busy I drink LA water it's
going to be like fatan all slush I eat
anything and I just did not have time
when I was having kids I was a crack
dealer I can't fucking be breastfeeding
no child with no razor blad and crack in
my other hand cuz it crack get in your
system so I'm like n this this ain't for
me and I don't want to be that I'm not
that kind of Mama yeah and it's also
it's just like it's you know it's a
beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
and then when they say the benefits are
but if you're stressed out it undo the
benefit you know the biggest light they
ta with breast oh I hate these bitches
they said oh my God if you breastfeed
it's going to tighten your stomach back
up should I get naked in here and show
you my stomach 37 years later
[Laughter]
my shit never went back flat I see you L
son of a bitch I don't had this girl up
here mascula me is that the right
word mascula that's the wrong
word what's playing with my
titties all this time
fuck I don't know what the word would be
are you think like are you talking about
masticating like the sounds
you yeah it just popped uh ma the Latin
root of I don't need it's mascula the
word mascul like emasculate no I don't
fucking know sometimes she just come out
of my mouth it don't make it m it's a
power move I kind of like it it made me
feel dumb masculate means the opposite
of it it means to make something more
masculine yeah she'll been making my
titty strong for no
reason so now I got one strong titty cuz
she don't like the fucking opposite side
and that one of my tit is just SC and
long oh the baby only wanted one side
yes and you know when they suck on your
tit they make you titty drag like dog
nipples you
don't just one is an utter and one oh oh
everybody I know breastfed got Cricket
titties no hey y'all Did you know did
you that you didn't that 35% of all
fatal accidents occur between 6:00 p.m.
and midnight and May maybe probably
allegedly by a guy named Kyle I made
that last part up do you know people
aged 25 to 34 have the highest amount of
drivers involved in car accidents y'all
out there trying to get your Pokemon go
on what are you doing and people aged 15
to 24 had the highest rate of emergency
room visits due to car accidents of all
age groups ah you guys tisk tisk and did
you know this weekend I was in Maine we
had to drive from Canada to a small town
in Maine in the pouring rain and did you
know that I died when I tell you we saw
four accidents on the side of the road
that did not look like they ended well
for anyone okay they weren't meat cutes
where someone met their husband or
anything like that I was I was shocked
okay did I yell out the window hey
Morgan and Morgan promo code Whitney I
sure did and I got a thumbs up from a
dead guy Morgan and Morgan is
American Morgan and Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm they have over
100 offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers with over 15 billion that's with
a B guys with over1 15 billion dollar
recovered for over 300,000 clients
Morgan and Morgan has a proven track
record of fighting to get you full and
fair compensation Morgan and Morgan has
been fighting for the people for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is so easy look being
a woman in Hollywood is hard submitting
an injury claim with Morgan and Morgan
is easy if you're ever injured you can
check out Morgan and Morgan their fee is
free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com
Whitney or dial pound law pound 529 from
your cell phone that's for fothe
people.com Whitney or pound law pound
529 from your cell phone this is a paid
advertisement yeah I was fighting with
someone about this the other day CU like
there are different souths you know like
I was in a fight with someone about like
do you keep your butter in the fridge or
out in the fridge that's psychotic to me
what why would you keep butter in the
because then you got to get you can't
spread it where I'm from in the South I
would get my ass beat if we put the
butter in the fridge you got to keep the
butter out in a butter dish out on the
table that shit nice but then you but
you got a top on it but then how are you
going to you got your toast you got your
suon how's it going to who the fuck just
eat butter like
that us
you butter at every meal you butter
bread when it's cold when you that's
what I'm saying if you take butter you
take butter and you you uh you if you're
going to use it that day you set it out
but we no we don't set and no we don't
set it out we butter ready at all times
no we don't butter ready at all time
that's why y'all
ining the eolive from the butter that's
been left out yeah I love trying to like
figure out these like flies and bugs
yeah but you got a dish on top it's like
a butter
dish an it's small that motherfucker fit
anything you ever been to the bathroom
and ants fell out of you like where the
fuck the ants come from they iner you
don't even know they in you it's the
parasites from the the table butter yes
and also just like from a very early age
I was like so paranoid because like when
you grow up in the South like there's
there nothing in the fridge is what you
think it is like you open the Lando
Lakes and it's just like a couple
chicken wings yeah cuz we use the we use
our butter our our country Croc like
every carton has some other shit we
didn't have no fucking country Croc I
was I would eat it today but that's a
little fancy shit we had that thick shit
where it didn't have just said butter it
didn't even tell it had no ingredient on
butter
try butter try me
yes so are you already um thinking of
stuff for season 4 like do you kind of
already go in with an idea oh we was
writing we was writing before to strike
it so we ready for season 4 cuz it's
going to be coming out like election
2024 or do you election 2025 cuz you're
in 2024
already uh I hope we can get back to
work soon so you know we can it's
probably going to be a quick turnaround
because you know we we should have been
out by now we should have been at least
we should be in last editing by now but
you know it is what it is we'll see what
happen and hopefully when all of this is
resol resolved we can get some residuals
and shit yep you think we going to get a
residual check no it's tricky like you
know I mean I think this this the
business has been broken for a really
long time there's just too many people
working on every show you know it used
to be like the amount of money that
these networks were able to command when
there were only three four networks it's
still based on that you know Bounty
Pampers they could only advertise on
three channels now if there's you know
15 channels there's 5,000 podcasts you
know everyone's making less money you
know and then these networks still have
10 Executives working on each show 10
people in the you know promo Department
Department 10 people in Human Resources
trying to make sure that you don't say
what you're saying in the room that
you're going to say you know what I mean
it's just like I'm not saying fire
people but it's just like as long as
this business is going to stay so
inflated and have two you know when you
go on your sitc there's 200 people there
who's paying for all you know it's it's
got to come from somewhere you know and
unfortunately it's like the person
that's generating all of it let me tell
them I give me 10 people we get Give me
the give me the cast and somebody in
crafty defeat me we don't need everybody
we we old cameras and running from act
it out and then turn the camera the next
W it's going to save us some money It's
Tricky cuz then you're like I don't want
people to get fired but it's like and
the unions are doing their job it's like
there's got to be three people on this
camera three people on this camera three
people on you know there's like safety
concerns but you're kind of like seeing
people on Instagram and Tik Tok making
really high quality shows with just
three people in their phone and you're
kind of like oh that's where those are
the people making the real money because
there's no overhead you know so it's
like it's just kind of this like
untenable situation but it's like for me
I like to go like do we really need 12
lawyers working on this see you know
when you get an email from someone and
you're like this is just 12 lawyers that
are probably getting paid 400 Grand a
year to be that are frankly slowing us
down that are being obstacles yeah you
know why don't you just like I would
just go in and clean house and go why
don't you just have a lawyer on an
hourly basis if you do
see that we need to license something
hire them for an hour $500 instead of
having them on retainer in the office
that you're paying real estate for or
like guess what everyone let all your
employees work from home so that you're
not paying you know for these offices in
Century City or Beverly Hill like
where's all this money going you know
someone's got to pay for all this shit
so it's just like I don't know I mean
Tyler Perry seems like he's kind of like
cracked it a little bit you know oh he
been corrected that's why he he he do
what he do he does it all himself and
then he just goes out and sells it CU
he's like I see the inefficiency here
like I know how to make the money but
you guys are spending it on stuff that's
not making the show better so let me
just do it on my own and then I'll sell
it to you Byron Allen does the same
thing yes and they both really rich
somebody doing something wrong yep and
it ain't bar and it ain't to M I'm
letting you go cuz I know you have to go
do um Jennifer Hudson can we just put
your tour dates up really quick let's
put your tour dates up um I don't know
how you're finding time to tour and have
a show come out and write a show but are
you doing a bunch of cities yes
Minneapolis Dallas Washington DC whoa
Philadelphia San Antonio Houston Atlanta
Chicago Cleveland Madison San Francisco
Portland Boston Oklahoma City yes
Memphis Tennessee Charlotte this is all
going to be starting October going
through March
16th yes Minneapolis this weekend ticket
Miss patc comedy.com I love you so much
thank you I hope I didn't keep you too
long no you didn't I cannot wait to send
uh my my new nephew he's Jordan oh name
my baby I can't think of a name huh I
can't think of a name you want a king a
who a king king no don't name the baby
king no uh well I wanted to do Maximus
but my last name is Cummings Maximus
Cummings oh he's not getting a daddy
last name no okay uh Maxim MC coms that
sound like I'm not
a what it sound like a c job you know
like the last name is a tough
pairing uh Tyler I like Tyler yeah Tyler
I like Tyler comings Tyler's good
Tyler's it's a little sorry it's a
little like Garrett is very Garrett I
like Garrett I have a Garrett I love
Garrett because I like I like gar
Grayson kind of cute um if you want to
go black uh Divine okay Divine Cummings
what's another black it settled little
Ray Ray little Ray Ray
Cummings Antoine Antoine Cummings yeahuh
there's a lot of black names I can give
you just send me all your birth
certificates I'll be able to pull one my
son name is n don't do that one uh I
have a Garrett um I'm trying to think a
Ronald I feel I think boys are harder
than girls I feel like nobody really
cares about boys
names I'm s I'm too Hest no name that
baby Tyler and keep it moving but but
not Maxima Maxima coming oh he sound
like supposed to yeah but we need to
give kids adversity I think you got to
give them a little name that's going to
you know make it hard for school because
whatever he's going to be he's going to
change it anyway that's so true he's I
live in California he's going to change
his gender by the time he's two if he
want to n you can't change your gender
if I got to buy you
shit I ain't gonna be out here buying
you no motherfucking Pokemons well you
know no you you well I support you but
hey when you get a certain age when you
pay for your own shit you can go full
blown the fuck out I I grew up poor when
you grew up poor you're whatever gender
your older sibling was yes whatever
hand-me-downs you got is what you got
that's right and if I catch you in my
lipstick and you ain't it ain't right
for you I'mma beat your ass and I think
I just settled it she's going to name
that baby
Tyler Miss Pat I love you so much I'll
it
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm